so a young woman allegedly put gorilla
glue in her hair and may sue the
manufacturer when i do my hair i like to
you know finish it off with a little got
to be glue spray well i didn't have any
more that could be glue space so i use
this
does she have a claim well in america
you can sue anyone for anything
at any time so you can file a lawsuit it
doesn't mean that you'll win but in
terms of product liability it all comes
down to the warning number one you don't
have a duty to warn about things that
aren't reasonably foreseeable was it
reasonably foreseeable that someone
would put this glue in their hair
maybe maybe not probably not number two
if you get over that hurdle then you
have to test the sufficiency of the
warning
was the warning that was given
sufficient and here the gorilla glue
said specifically
don't bring it in contact with skin and
other body parts
that's probably going to be sufficient
but again you can file suit it doesn't
mean you're going to win but come on
you already knew that and here's some
more advice subscribe or i will see you
in court